Tout ça pour les travaux qui se
donneront sur trois ans puissent
avoir lieu sacré trop de
congestion.
FRANÇOIS BONNARDEL, ministre
des Transports du Québec
- Il n'y a personne qui a du fun
à passer... à passer une heure,
une heure et demi dans son auto.
- Son évaluation repose
sur le fait que jusqu'à 60 % des
usagers quotidiens du tunnel,
soit 72 000 automobilistes,
devront adapter leurs habitudes
et choisir le transport en
du moins pendant
les trois ans que
dureront les travaux.
- Chose certaine, l'auto solo
s'avère la pire des solutions.
- Et les travaux, ils doivent
e de prolonger de 40 ans
la durée de vie du tunnel,
emprunté par 120 000
automobilistes, chaque jour.
Dès le 31 octobre, jour de
l'Halloween, les automobilistes
devront donc composer avec une
voie ouverte en direction
de la Rive-Sud, deux voies
en direction de Montréal.
Bref, l'ensemble d
devraient multiplier par quatre
le temps de traverser
le pont-tunnel de MontréalMontrl
vers la Rive-Sud et
par trois en sens inverse.
CHANTAL inistre resp.
de la Métropole et région de Mtl
- On a mis en place des mesures
comme la gratuité de certaines
lignes d'autobus. On ajoute à ça
des voies réservées, plus de
navettes vers les stations de
métro, des stationnements
incitatifs.
- Pour bien des gens, ça va
quand même assez compliqué.
- C'est sûr qu'on ne planifie
pas aller sur la Rive-Sud à
partir du mois de novembre.
- C'est pas facile,
mais on n'a pas le choix.
- Une chance que j'habite pas
sur la Rive-Sud!
(rire)
- Les camionneurs,
qui constituent 13 % de
l'achala le tunnel,
craignent une rupture
d'approvisionnement.
MARC CADIEUX, président et d.g.
Association du camionnage du Qc
- Certai certains
moments, il pourrait y avoir des
ruptures de la chaîne logistique
et de l'approvisionnement
sur ces périodes-là.
- D'ici là, le gouvernement
de plus que jamais aux
usagers de se trouver un plan B
et de connaître les mesures
à leur dispositioge
quebec.ca/lafontaine pour
survivre à la congestion.
Ici Gabulx,
Radio-Canada, Mon